is how they're turning into different people;
how they're being transformed.
How words are empowering them with a dignity they had never known,
that they couldn't even imagine.
They had no idea such dignity could come from them.
At the workshop, in that beloved hell we share, we all give something.
We open our hands and hearts and give what we have, what we can.
All of us; all of us equally.
And so you feel that at least in a small way
you're repairing that huge social fracture
which makes it so that for many of them,
prison is their only destination.
I remember a verse by a tremendous poet, a great poet,
from our Unit 48 workshop, Nicolás Dorado:
"I will need an infinite thread to sew up this huge wound."
Poetry does that; it sews up the wounds of exclusion.
It opens doors. Poetry works as a mirror.
It creates a mirror, which is the poem.
They recognize themselves, they look at themselves in the poem
and write from who they are, and are from what they write.
In order to write,
they need to appropriate the moment of writing
which is a moment of extraordinary freedom.
They have to get into their heads, search for that bit of freedom
that can never be taken away when they write
and that is also useful to realize that freedom is possible
even inside a prison,
and that the only bars we have in our wonderful space
is the word "bars,"
and that all of us in our hell burn with happiness
when we light the wick of the word.
(Applause)
I told you a lot about the prison, a lot about what I experience
every week, and how I enjoy it and transform myself with the inmates.
But you don't know how much I'd like it
if you could feel, live, experience, even for a few seconds,
what I enjoy every week and what makes me who I am.
(Applause)
Martín Bustamante: The heart chews tears of time;
blinded by that light,
it hides the speed of existence
where the images go rowing by.
It fights; it hangs on.
The heart cracks under sad gazes,
rides on storms that spread fire,
lifts chests lowered by shame,
knows that it's not just reading and going on,
it also wishes to see the infinite blue.
The heart sits down to think about things,
fights to avoid being ordinary,
tries to love without hurting,
breathes the sun, giving courage to itself,
surrenders, travels toward reason.
The heart fights among the swamps,
skirts the edge of the underworld,
falls exhausted, but won't give in to what's easy,
while irregular steps of intoxication
wake up,
wake the stillness.
I'm Martín Bustamante,
I'm a prisoner in Unit 48 of San Martín,
today is my day of temporary release.
And for me, poetry and literature have changed my life.
Thank you very much!
Cristina Domenech: Thank you!
(Applause)